Hi class. So we're going to go through a little epithelial test test quiz. So have
a paper and pencil out. You're going to be writing down your answers. That way you will
practice writing your answers, practice your spelling. I'm going to be doing this along
with you. So I'll be writing my answers down to which will give me some indication on how
long it should take you. So it's just to kind of get you up to speed for any lab or lab
practical or quiz exam that you might have. So make sure you have pencil and paper. It's
going to be 25 questions. So let's get started. Question one. Name the epithelial tissue facing
the lumen. I labeled the lumen here for you. So this is the epithelial tissue that's surrounding
this entire lumen here. What type of epithelial tissue is that? So go ahead and write it down.
Question two. Name the epithelial tissue facing the lumen. Number three. Pointer in the lumen.
Name the epithelial tissue facing the lumen. So look real close at those apical cells. That
was just a hint. Won't be getting any hints on an exam. So number four. Pointers in the
lumen. Name that epithelial tissue. Number five. Pointer in the lumen. Name the epithelial
tissue facing the lumen. And tell me where you could find this type of epithelial tissue
in your body.
Number six. Here's your lumen. Name this epithelial tissue facing the lumen. And kind of knowing
what this is, what is the function of this epithelial tissue in this location? So first
name the epithelial tissue in its function in this location.
Number seven. Pointer is in the lumen of one of the many structures seen here. Nothing
else looks like this. What organ is this from? Not the type of epithelial tissue. Just what
organ is this from? Nothing else looks like this. Number eight. There's your epithelial
tissue. Where in your body is this found? Tell me where you could find it. So pointer
is in the lumen. Name that epithelial tissue facing the lumen. Now here's a close up of
that slide we just saw. Pointers in the lumen. So here's kind of like a fuzzy border, this
edging that is right there facing the lumen. What is this called? What is this apical modification
called right here? And what is its function? So you don't need to tell me the type of epithelium
here. Just what is this apical modification called this fuzzy looking thing here? And
what is its function?
So number eleven. Pointers in the lumen. Name the epithelial tissue facing the lumen.
Let's just add a second part to this. I'm going to add, and where would you find this?
So number twelve. Pointer in the lumen. Name this epithelial tissue facing the lumen.
So you're going to be seeing a lot of slides that are just repeats of the same tissue,
epithelial tissue type. I just want to have you see it multiple times and multiple different
pictures till you finally go. I got it. I got it. Number thirteen. Name that epithelial
tissue facing the lumen. Make sure you're specific with this one.
Thirteen. Here's fourteen. So this is a whole mount slide. In the lecture videos we went
over what that was. So what type of epithelial tissue is this? And what is its special name
that we give it? So name the type of epithelial tissue this is and its special name.
Fifteen. So the pointer is pointing at that white structure. What is that structure called
and what does that white structure make? So sixteen. Name the epithelial tissue facing
the lumen. Don't pay any attention to the pointer here. Just look at the epithelial tissue
and make sure you give me this specific one that is shown here.
Number seventeen. Looking at this slide. What organ is this from? What organ is this from?
Oh I get right in the lumen but name the epithelial tissue facing the lumen. We've got lots of
lumens here. And what is the function of this epithelial tissue in this location? So that's
number eighteen. Nineteen. Name this epithelial tissue. And what is
the function of this type of epithelial tissue?
Okay number twenty. This is kind of a blurry slide. I wish I was in the classroom to get
a better picture. But name the epithelial tissue facing the lumen. Here I'm showing you
a lumen that's filled with red blood cells. So name that type of epithelial tissue facing
this lumen. And what's its special name that we give it?
Number twenty one. What are the apical structures that are facing lumen called? And what do they
do? Twenty two. So what is this epithelial tissue facing the lumen? And where can you
find this in your body?
What is structure number twenty three? What is structure labeled A? And what is its function
twenty four. So what type of tissue is located where I scribbled in this green line? So what
is this tissue down here called? Just the general tissue name. I'm going to add one more thing
to this question. And why is it important? And why is that tissue important to our epithelial
tissue?
And your last question, here's that whole mount slide again. Where do you find this epithelial
tissue in your body? So that's the end of our epithelial tissue quiz. So now we're going
to go back and we're going to see how you guys did. So name this epithelial tissue facing
the lumen. Simple squamous. This is simple squamous. One layer thick, simple squamous
because these nuclei are flat. Name this epithelial tissue. Well we know it's got cilia. It looks
columnar because these nuclei are elongated. And it looks like more than one layer thick.
But you know that's not what it is. It is pseudo stratified. We do not have stratified
cilate columnar epithelium. So this is pseudo stratified meaning falsely stratified cilate
columnar epithelium. Pseudo stratified cilate columnar epithelium. Basement membrane would
be somewhere down here. Cilia. Goblet cells are sort of stratified columnar stuff here.
That was number two. Number three. Pointer in the lumen. We know this is stratified. It's
more than one layer thick. But you look at those apical cells. These are weird dome shaped
cells. This one looks like it's got two nuclei in it. Just weird looking cells. This is transitional
epithelial tissue. This one. Easy weasy. Look at those nice round nuclei. One layer thick.
This is simple cuboidal. Name this epithelium. Once again we have our cilia. We've got our
elongated nuclei. It looks stratified but we know it's not. Basement membrane going to
be somewhere down here. This is pseudo stratified ciliated columnar epithelium. Where can you
find this? You find it in your large airways that are taking air into your lungs. So most
of these slides are taken from your trachea. But large airways carrying air. You've already
seen a similar slide to this. Name this epithelial tissue facing the lumen. This one is so beautiful.
Look at this. This is simple squamous. Yes. This is the kidney. This is in the kidney.
This is a glomerulus. We are taking blood and what's the function of the simple squamous.
We are filtering that blood. We're going to filter that blood to start making urine.
So the function of this simple squamous is filtration. What organ is this from? Nothing
else looks like this. These are little alveoli where we have gas exchange. We have millions
of them. This is the lung. We'll see these in another slide. I just asked you which organ
this was. So I have to put down as the lungs. But this is all simple squamous. All simple
squamous. Where do you find this in your body? What kind of epithelium is it? This is transitional.
Look at those apical cells. Weird looking cells. It's stratified. But the apical cells
are telling you what it is. This is transitional epithelium. It is found in your bladder and
your ureter. The ureters are carrying urine into your bladder. Remember why it's called
transitional. When this bladder, if this was the bladder and this is the lumen, the bladder
as the bladder fills up with urine, it's pushing down on these apical cells and it's making
them flat. So these big balloon cells are transitioning into flat cells. So transitional epithelium.
Bladder and ureters. Did I already ask this? Oh my gosh. I don't know if I already asked
this. This looks familiar. Oh that's because I just gave you the quiz. Oh I just saw this.
Number nine. What is the epithelium facing the lumen? The pointer is in the lumen. You
look here. This is really easy to see. Your basement membrane is going to be somewhere
down here. This is all connective tissue. This is simple. This is simple columnar. Simple
columnar. The nuclei are towards the basement membrane. Simple columnar. Here's a close
up of our simple columnar cells right here. Here's our lumen. The apical modification
is fuzzy border. This is microvilli. Microvilli. Some places will call it a brush border because
it kind of looks like a brush. It's just a fuzzy edge here. Unlike cilia, cilia you can
really see. This is just kind of a blurry, blurry, blurry edge. What's its function?
Microvilli increase the surface area of the cells for absorption. So wherever you have
microvilli, they're increasing the surface area for absorption. So pointer in the lumen
here. You've got lots of these in this slide. This one is easy-weasy. What is this epithelial
tissue? Simple cuboidal. Where do you find that? You're going to find this in the kidney
tubules. Lots of tubules in the kidney and in glands. Pointer in the lumen. What's this
epithelial tissue? Here's the epithelial tissue. Here's going to be your basement membrane
somewhere around here. So it's stratified, but look at the top layer. Weird dome looking
cells. This is transitional. Transitional. Easy-weasy. Here's going to be your basement
membrane somewhere down here. This is connective tissue. Here's your epithelial tissue. It's
stratified more than one layer thick. You look to the top. Those cells on the top have
their flat, flat nuclei. This is stratified squamous, non-caratinized. You have to put
down if their keratinized or non-caratinized. Non-caratinized. These cells are still alive
up here. So this is non-caratinized stratified squamous. Here's that whole mount slide again.
What type of epithelial tissue is this? And what's its special name? So the type of epithelial
tissue is simple squamous. Right? This is simple squamous. You're looking down at this plate
of cells. Here's the cell border. This is simple squamous. What's its special name? Mesothelium.
Poynther pointing to a goblet cell. What do goblet cells make? They make mucus. They
make mucus. Now remember, goblet cells are found in your airways and in your GI tract.
So depending on where they are, it's going to determine the function of that mucus. This
is PSCC. This isn't probably in the tracheus. It's a stratified cilia columbinar. So this
mucus is just being made, is going to be put down on the surface of these cells and the
cilia here are going, and its function is to trap any air particles. So you don't take
those air particles deep into your lungs. So depends on where those goblet cells are,
what their function is going to be. Name the epithelial tissue. Well you know it's stratified.
This is pretty big. This is skin. So when we get to the integumentary system, you will
know, oh this is lard. This is thick, thick skin. So this is stratified squamous keratinized.
So all this is dead. This is just old cells that have been filled up. These cells have
started to die. They filled up with keratin, so now they're dead. So stratified squamous
keratinized. What organ is this from? You see lots of these structures. Lots of these.
Here's the lumen of all these structures. So you'll learn about these when we learn about
the urinary system. But this is where we're making urine. So this is the kidney. Name the
epithelial tissue facing the lumen. We've got lots of lumens here. You've already seen
this earlier when I showed you the big picture of the lungs. So what is this, this epithelium
is what? It's a simple squamous. And what is its function here? This is in the lungs.
So we're going to have diffusion of gases, carbon dioxide and oxygen. So this is diffusion
of gases. We are in the lungs. That's simple squamous of the lungs, diffusion of gases.
Here we have another stratified squamous. Cells are alive up here. Non-characterized.
The thicker, the more strata you have, the more layers you have of cells, the more protection
you are going to have. So if it's stratified, its function is going to be protection. Where
and tear. Name the epithelial tissue facing this lumen. Not a very good picture, but you
can make it out. You know this is a blood vessel because the lumen is filled with red
blood cells. This is simple squamous. This is called endothelium, endothelium. The function
in blood vessels is to provide a smooth surface for blood to flow over. So the question here
is what are these apical structures facing the lumen? This is cilia. What do they do?
Cilia are motile hair-like extensions that move. They are moving in one direction to
move whatever is above them in this tube. So if you've got mucus, we can kind of see
a goblet cell here. This is in the airway. So it's moving the mucus. It's moving the
mucus away from the lungs and up towards your mouth so you can swallow it. Remember we talked
about nicotine. It paralyzes these cilia so they stop functioning. So you get your smokers
cough every morning clearing out that mucus. Question 22, what's this epithelium? You've
already seen it once before, but I wanted to show you another picture. Simple columnar.
Simple columnar. Here's the basement membrane. Here's the connective tissue layer, elongated
nuclei. Here's a goblet cell. Simple columnar. Where do you find this? Stomach, small intestines,
large intestines. So what is this structure labeled A? This is a nice, this is a beautiful
picture. This is a goblet cell. What kind of epithelium is this? Simple columnar. And
you can actually see the microvilli up here. I mean, can't see them, but you can see this
edging really well. And here's your lumen. So what's the function of goblet cells here?
We're making mucus. This is probably in the small intestines. So we said it partly is
to lube the tube. Remember there's food in here. Food that's being digested and absorbed.
So we're lubing the tube so that food can keep on moving down the tube and it's adding
protection. It's giving us a mucus protection for these cells also. So what type of tissue
is in this region where the green lines are? We said this, this is, this is our epithelial
tissue. Deep to all epithelial tissue is what? Connective tissue. Why is this connective
tissue important to our epithelial tissue? Remember one of the characteristics of epithelial
tissue is it is a vascular. There is no blood, no blood flowing through the epithelial tissue.
This connective tissue just deep to the epithelial tissue is very vascular and it is the source
of the nutrients and oxygen to this epithelial tissue. Those nutrients and oxygen are going
to diffuse through that basement membrane and diffuse into our epithelial tissue. Very
important. Whole mount slide. So this is simple squamous mesothelium. Where do you find it?
This forms your serous membranes. You have your visceral and parietal pleura around
the lungs, visceral and parietal. Paracardium around your heart and visceral and parietal
peritoneum that is in your abdominal cavity. So that, oh that's it. So hopefully you did
well. I went about as fast as you should be going on an exam. Once you see these you should
just be able to look at it and go, I know what that is. Write it down, practice your writing.
Whenever you're writing down a tissue, always ask yourself those questions. What's its function?
Where can I find it? What organ is this from? Stuff like that. So you're reinforcing everything
that you should be learning. So that's it. So we are going to go on to connective tissue.